ans
bonjour stéphane berlot bienvenue au
bistrot du thé assis à vous je vous en
prie merci venez vous installer pour ce
nouveau numéro du café politique
émission qui nous permet de parler du
parcours des élus de leurs engagements
mais aussi un peu de l'actualité vous le
verrez tout à l'heure et bien de voir ça
vous avez 47 ans mère de villepreux
deuxième mandat adhérent à l'ump puis
aux républicains
mais la majorité que vous portez et sans
étiquette il ya de visionner cette
affaire il est aussi le vice-président
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge
du budget et de la programmation
pluriannuelle des investissements alors
saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement deux
mois après l'officialisation de ce
mariage avec villepreux vous vous en
pensez quoi vous en êtes satisfait c'est
difficile c'est difficile parce qu'il
faut se rappeler d'où on vient il ya
quelques mois encore l'état voulait que
nous créions une intercommunalité à plus
de 850 mille habitants nous n'avons pas
eu le temps disons le très clairement de
réfléchir de travailler ensemble de
trouver le temps de définir un projet
pour le territoire de saint quentin en
effet nous avons été au plus vite et
maintenant c'est toute la suite qui
reste encore à faire et on a beaucoup
d'espoir et on a beaucoup d'énergie et
d'ambition pour les prochains mois sur
l'idée de l'intercommunalité même vous
étiez plutôt critique au début on vous
disait qu'en général les intercoms ne
faisait pas vraiment leurs preuves et je
suis encore je me suis encore ce que je
pense sincèrement que les
intercommunalités n'ont pas fait encore
leurs preuves notamment sur les parties
qui nous tiennent tout particulièrement
à coeur notamment les optimisations
budgétaires et les synergies entre les
différents services au niveau des villes
je n'ai encore rien vu venir mais je
souhaite absolument saint-quentin soit
une belle réussite je veux tout faire
maintenant pour participer à ce beau
dessin et à faire tout pour que comme je
voulais dit que ce soit une belle
intercours et une intercours avec
beaucoup d'envié de choses à faire
le but d'une interview pour vous c'est
de faire des économies ou sa dot leurs
ambitions il faut réellement revenir au
fondement même d'une intercommunalité
des intercommunalités à la base ont été
créés pour créer de la richesse pour
redistribuer aux villes et très vite on
s'est perdus on a fait énormément de
choses donc je pense qu'il faut que
l'intercommunalité maintenant on en
revienne aux fondements mêmes
l'attractivité pour créer de la richesse
c'est la priorité numéro une
on a réalisé un petit micro-trottoir
dans votre commune ça nous allons vois
aller voir pardon mais elle les
habitants leur demander attendez je vous
laisse réagir juste après écoute et son
développement par exemple des transports
ou même des animations ou des commerces
aussi des commerces la ville point que
ce que j'attends ce qu'il fasse une
piste cyclable sportif celui qui veut
courir ce serait moins dangereux quoi je
pense que ça va être bien au niveau des
écoles et des choses comme ça sur saint
quentin en yvelines il ya des piscines
peut-être des prix réduits pour les
habitants de villepreux
ça peut être complémentaire dont voilà
quoi que lévis se rapproche et ça a
peut-être coûté moins cher aussi haut
niveau un financement
j'attends que les communes s'entend bien
et fendeille faso des choses en commun
il y avait des choses concrètes le
transport alors ça oui à une façon alors
pour la partie transport c'est une
compétence que nous portons et elle
participe pleinement à l'attractivité
bien sûr si on veut créer de la richesse
ou si on veut notre si on souhaite que
les entreprises viennent il faut
développer certaines choses et les
transports c'est une priorité aussi ce
que je vois aussi c'est qu'on mélange un
peu tout veille parce qu'il ya métaux
alors il y aura des réductions
je crois que la preuve en est qu'il ya
beaucoup de pédagogie à faire je pense
que les habitants de villes peu comme
beaucoup d'habitants danser dans les
cinq villes qui arrive aujourd'hui ça va
encore mal ce que l'intercommunalité
portes et ce que je retiens aussi c'est
quelque chose qui me tient tout
particulièrement à coeur souvent quand
on parle intercommunalités on entend
toujours du plus j'aimerais bien qu'il y
ait ça en plus faut faire attention
avant tout travaillons sur
l'optimisation des coûts préparons et
bâtissons un socle
financier sur lequel nous pourrons alors
penser autre chose
mais avant tout allons-y dans le calme
et essayons de prévoir certainement
beaucoup de projets mais après ce n'est
peut-être pas la priorité numéro une
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on a entendu aussi
dans le micro trottoir c'est la volonté
que les communes s'entendent bien alors
s'il va mener c'est la question suivante
aujourd'hui avec les communes de dit de
gauche est un petit peu plus compliqué
au sein de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines comment vous
percevez les choses je pense que c'est
compliqué avec les douze communes parce
que ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'on a
créé une intercommunalité avec des
villes qui sont ne se ressemblent pas
qu'ils ont des histoires qui n'ont rien
à voir on a voulu mettre cette ville qui
ont une histoire depuis 40 ans avec des
villes qui ont une perception totalement
opposé de ce que peut être
l'intercommunalité nous nous vivons dans
les contraintes budgétaires
depuis 2008 pour nous et on arrive dans
une intercommunalité qui n'a pas eu à
vivre cela seul nom sur les deux
dernières années il ya tout à faire et
c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir un peu un
choc des cultures
mais on va tout faire pour qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble et essayer d'adopter
un fonctionnement commun et ça dépasse
les étiquettes gauche droite si je pense
que oui mais il y a sûrement une
perception différente de ce qu'est une
intercommunalité peut-être avec des
villes plus à droite qui avait des
villes un petit peu plus haut à gauche
personnellement et moi qui représente
plus le courant au niveau de la droite
je pense qu'il faut nous recentrer sur
les compétences comme je voulais dit
qu'ils sont vraiment les compétences les
plus importantes et laisser des villes
gérées peut-être d'autres compétences
plus facultative est en lien direct avec
la proximité qu un maire doit avoir avec
sa ville et sa population
à 50 ans nevin dans cette nouvelle
intercall vous êtes en charge du budget
de la programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements
ça va consister en quoi alors déjà le
gros travail sur le budget ça va être de
refaire si on
laisse la possibilité de refaire ce
qu'on a fait dans nos villes comment
quand on est arrivé en 2008 que je
voulais dis nous je vis la crise depuis
je crois je suis arrivé en 2008 c'est à
dire
éplucher toutes les lignes de cou et
voir ce qu'il est possible de faire pour
faire aussi bien moins cher ou peut-être
un tout petit peu moins bien et moins
cher aussi ça c'est la première priorité
il va falloir qu'on aille travailler sur
toutes les grosses lignes toutes les
grosses masses et puis
ne pas dire que ce n'est pas possible
dire il faut réfléchir à tous on peut
tous pensé on peut tout imaginer et il
faut avouer un treillage ça c'est la
première priorité et le plan pluriannuel
d'investissement s'est réellement bâtir
un plan pluriannuel parce que nous ne
pouvons plus aujourd'hui avec les
baisses de dotations de l'état avoir une
vision sur le court terme on doit
réellement se projeter sur les
prochaines années sur les cinq
prochaines années avec une problématique
qui va être de taille faire cohabiter
les sept communes qui avaient l'habitude
de travailler entre est disons le et
avec les cinq villes qui entre avec
beaucoup d'envié
on va laisser de côté cette actualité
liée à l'intercommunalité et on va
passer en salle pour recevoir
conversations allaient aller aussi
c'était fade mirambeau vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maire de
villepreux adhérents les républicains je
disais tout à l'heure c'est votre
deuxième mandat dans cette commune
commune que vous avez découvert à quelle
occasion fin des années 90 alors aux
environs des années 95 en fait je
travaillais au clae et j'avais
l'habitude de prendre la route et
j'arrivais sur villepreux et je suis
tombé amoureux de cette ville ce quand
j'arrivais je regardais à gauche je
voyais les champs et quand je regardais
à droite je voyais la plaine et je suis
tombé amoureux de cette ville et avant
de la connaître j'ai voulu y vivre et
j'ai pu acheter et je suis avide produit
97 maintenant pourquoi avoir évolué
entre devenir le maire parce qu'on peut
être séduit par une commune sans pour
autant en prendre la tête
je pense que si on veut que les choses
changent il faut se donner les moyens
pour pouvoir le faire et donc je
trouvais que la commune n'était pas à
gérer comme il le fallait et pour gérer
une ville
il faut être mère donc je me suis lancé
là dedans et avec beaucoup de force
ça n'a pas été facile parce que je
venais de nulle part en fait un jeu
n'était pas adjoint je n'avais rien fait
avant il a fallu tout content tout
construire mais c'était passionnant
c'était votre premier engagement
politique vous aviez auparavant votre
carte déjà l'ump ou tout à fait magique
du rpr j'ai pris ma carte d'affaires
plus en ses revers quand j'avais 30 ans
était aux environs de l'année 2000 pour
soutenir jacques chirac dans sa
candidature et par rejet un petit peu
disons le de la gauche plurielle je
trouvais que lionel jospin son
gouvernement avait beaucoup de choses
entre les mains pour pouvoir réformer la
france c'est ce qu'il avait proposé à
savoir les 35 heures ne me satisfaisait
pas c'était votre première campagne donc
cette campagne de taff réunit six pales
de 2008 et voulait l'emporter au second
tour avec 26 voix d'avancé ils voient
des heures la numéro retente socialiste
depuis 13 ans michelle valladon
est votre sentiment à ce moment là avec
26 points d'avance une joie immense
parce qu'on nous attendait pas à
on nous attendait réellement pas il y
avait trois listes en place nous avions
fait je croise 27% le lors du premier
tour merci monsieur lors du premier tour
donc personne ne nous attendait la maire
actuelle en place avait fait 47 pour son
don qu'elle devait absolument l'emporter
on l'a on a gagné par 26 voix
ça a été une joie immense et puis aussi
un coup parce que quelques heures après
voir quelques minutes après quand je me
suis retrouvé seul je me suis dit que le
travail
elle est réellement être là et qu'il y
avait énormément de choses à faire dans
cette ville vous aviez des mots durs
envers votre adversaire lors de la
deuxième campagne celle de 2014
michelle valladon revient cette fois ci
pour conseiller la nouvelle candidate
socialiste maintenant j'ai de bons bilbo
vous avez déclaré la candidate
socialiste vous appelle au secours comme
si la médiocrité pouvait venir à l'aide
au néant et au vide ça c'est des mots de
campagne et je partage ma campagne
on peut se permettre ce genre de chose
d'autant plus qu'on se fait en fait
attaqué
de manière très très vive donc plus on
vous attaque et plus vous avez le droit
de réponse et quand on m'attaque je sais
tout à fait répondre je vous pose cette
question pour voir un peu votre vision
aussi de la politique il faut savoir se
montrer dur quelquefois il faut savoir
sont très dur et je pense que les
électeurs ceux qui votent pour vous ont
besoin aussi que vous ayez de la force
on n'aime pas les gens les gens
mouraient les gens terne les gens qui
n'ont pas d'énergie faut savoir dire les
choses et quand on vous attaque faut
savoir répondre il faut savoir se battre
bien sûr quitte à être quelquefois aussi
dans l'erreur il faut savoir le
reconnaître il met pas trop prendre des
positions il faut il faut 100 mais ça
m'arrive rarement dans l'erreur et merci
le mandat des pour partir et lui l'est
républicain ancien ump ancien rpr mais
on le disait aussi tout à l'heure votre
liste vous la présenter comme sans
étiquette alors pourquoi aussi ce choix
de sans étiquette
alors faites à la basse et les pas mon
choix j'étais militant rpr sur la ville
il n'y avait qu'une opposition assez
faible et je mettais tout directement
tournés vers l'arrêt des raids je
représentais pour avoir évidemment et
peut-être de lui on avait jugé que
j'étais trop jeune que je n'avais aucune
expérience et qu'un autre candidat
pouvait défendre les couleurs du rpr et
du centre devient beaucoup plus efficace
donc j'ai accepté ça pas été simple bien
évidemment mais parce que c'est des
choses dures à entendre et nous avons
décidé de partir
avec une liste qui n'avaient pas
d'étiquette et au fil des semaines on a
été de plus en plus confiants dans notre
choix
parce que quand on se présente pour une
élection dans une commune de 10000
habitants parlent pas de droite ou de
gauche
on parle de la vie des gens et donc je
sais pas une élection où la couleur à un
rôle vraiment important et ce choix je
le revendique et je les revendique et
après parce qu'en 2014 alors que
j'aurais pu avoir l'investiture je ne
vais pas demander à ce que quand vous
faites un choix 2008 vous faites le même
après il ya aucune raison de changer et
ce que je pensais en 2008 je le pense
encore maintenant vous dites sur une
commune gauche droite finalement ça
assez peu assez peu d'intérêt
en fait votre regarde bien on se
chamaille c'est un peu le jeu politique
mais on est d'accord sur beaucoup de
choses mais c'est le jeu il faut qu'il
ait une droite et une gauche puis c'est
aussi bien que les gens puissent avoir
le choix
moi je suis pas pour consensus à tout
prix je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
gauche et une droite pour que les idées
un peu ont et qui en fait un débat
tu apprends que le consensus à tout prix
me fait peur il faut qu'ils aient en un
clivage fort pour que les gens au moins
est un choix ils se disent pas mais ce
sont tous les mêmes
plus jeune vous aviez déjà cet
engagement politique alors je me suis
pas une cet engagement est né parce que
moi j'ai une histoire je me souviens
encore quand je regarde très très loin
moi j'ai vu ma mère qui pleurait le 10
mai 81 quand elle a vu françois
mitterrand à apparaître sur l'écran est
comme mon père a déclaré la france est
foutue et je pense que ça ça vous touche
quand vous avez 13 ans et j'ai vécu avec
cela et j'ai adhéré au comité de soutien
de jacques chirac dès 1988 dont j'avais
à peine 20 ans mais j'ai réellement
voulu aller plus loin aux environs de
2002 quand j'avais à peine 30 ans on
parlait des socialistes peut-être aussi
un peu des républicains maintenant parce
que l'actualité récente pour votre
formation politique c'est aussi la mise
en examen de nicolas sarkozy qui est
quand même le patron des républicains
pour finacement financement par don
illégal de sa présidentielle de sa
campagne en 2012
vous en pensez-quoi qui sont la taxe
sarkozy
moi je ne sais pas je vais pas m'en
mêler on sait je ne suis pas juge mais
je trouve quand même impressionnant
qu'un homme puisse être attaquée à ce
point et n'être jamais inculpés de rien
on devrait se poser des questions quand
même je pense vous êtes comme christian
estrosi nous avons tous un devoir de
solidarité avec nicolas sarkozy c'est ce
qu'il dit oui en tout cas au moins
aujourd'hui rien ne prouve de toute
façon qu'il est coupable de quoi que ce
soit donc on doit aller dans ce sens et
puis de toute façon nicolas sarkozy dans
la courte histoire au niveau des cds et
lui reste mon choix de coeur il a
participé aussi je me souviens très bien
de son discours lors de sa prise de la
présidence de l'ump ya quelques années
maintenant sa force m'avait aussi donner
envie de m'engager
c'est à dire que s'il est candidat pour
la primaire à droite ce sera votre
candidat j'ai dit que c'était le choix
du coeur
le choix de la raison je ne sais pas
encore la petite erreur les candidats
ouais un peu trop je pense sont huit ou
neuf aujourd'hui annoncer sa candidature
on parlait pas y aller on parle de
perdre demain mais alors je ne sais pas
s'ils ont vraiment envie ou c'est pour
exister
ou alors de peut-être de revivre ce que
manuel valls a fait mais on n'est pas
tous manuel valls et je pense que ce qui
est arrivé nous peut éventuellement ne
pas se reproduire avec eux ne tombons
pas dans le riz le ridicule je pense que
ça fait un peu trop de candidats et
quand vous vous présentez réellement à
une primaire c'est qu'il faut avoir une
chance sinon mieux vaut rester à côté
mais ça fait mal à votre famille
politique et à la politique en général à
votre avis sinon la situation
8 9 15 candidats parce que c'est ça le
débat est justement peut-être 15 20
il faudrait il faut laisser le choix il
faut laisser la liberté aux gens de le
faire et ce qu'il faudrait surtout ça
pourrait faire du mal surtout si après
la primaire on n'arrivait pas justement
à s'unir pour porter le candidat qui
arrivera en tête
nous avons réalisé un petit
micro-trottoir sur cette question des
primaires à droite justement voici
quelques réactions
allons-y
non il n'est jamais assez y a pas les
bons
moi personnellement je trouve qu'ils
sont trop bas qui représente la droite
il y aura quelque chose pas quelques
variantes pride vrac d'accord c'est leur
problème si paul biya pour l'instant
c'est pas aussi une encore beaucoup mais
oui je crois qu'il ya encore un qui va
se décider dans pas longtemps
oui voix y en avoir beaucoup je trouve
ça ridicule en général mais peut il sans
gros mieux ça sera
alors pourquoi bah faut de la
concurrence quand même faut de la
concurrence ça dans sa différence dans
la vie de la classe politique
et oui finalement sur le terrain vous en
tant qu'élu vous êtes le premier élu que
les gens rencontrent aussi - et déjà il
ne me parle pas de ça mais je ne vois
pas en quoi ça gêne réellement qui est
10 15 ou 20 il faut laisser la
possibilité aux gens de ces de
s'exprimer oui nous aurons de toute
façon l'ensemble des des candidats font
partie du même mouvement est globalement
le socle de leur programme sera le même
donc je les trouve très très dur mais ça
montre aussi qu'il y à un désaveu très
clair des français pour la vie politique
et pourrait pour leurs élus et c'est ce
qui est peut-être le plus grave et je
suis obligé de faire le lien avec ce
qu'on a vécu à la fin de l'année 2015 et
avec le vote massif pour le pour le fn
parce que quand des gens sont à ce point
suspicieux de la classe politique
ils peuvent arriver à voter pour les
extrêmes ans à venir que les politiques
ont du travail sont beaucoup de travail
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup il
faut qu'il se remette en cause et faut
qu'ils écoutent les français arrêtent de
promettre n'importe quoi c'est ce que
nous avons vécu et je vais te un petit
peu du rendement 2012 avec le président
actuel ait eu beaucoup de promesses
quand vous n'en tenez aucune
les françaises s'en rappelle après et
vont vers les extrêmes
votre vision politique c'est plutôt le
libéralisme lors de vos voeux à la
population par des réformes libérales le
chancelier allemand ait le courage de
prendre les mesures impopulaires dans un
premier temps mais qui ont donné les
résultats que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et ça c'est votre vision
politique sur libéralisme bien sûr
libéralisme et prend
enfin les réformes qu'il faut pour notre
pays
et là je le dis avec une force parce que
c'est incroyable qu'on n'arrive pas à le
faire depuis des années ça marche
ailleurs il y un immobilisme en france
et je pense que cet immobilisme comme je
l'avais dit aussi n'est de l'obsession
de la réélection dès que vous êtes élu
ils sont obsédés par la ré élection et
ne faut plus rien et en tant que bien
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas la
tentation aussi quelquefois de
fonctionner de la même manière et non et
c'est pour ça que je veux garder ma
profession et je suis un élu particulier
car je suis en activité encore et
justement je veux rester en activité
pour garder ma liberté d'expression et
pouvoir dire ce que j'ai envie de dire
je n'attends rien de ce monde là si en
2020 je me représentais et que par
change et y est lui très bien si j'étais
battu jeu tournerait la page et je
reprendrai ma vie je n'attends rien de
personne et je pense que c'est le
problème peut-être de tous nos élites
actuelles vous arriver à concilier vie
professionnelle et vie politique c'est
très très dur avec cinq ans d'un montant
en plus haut je peux vous le dire mais
je me bats pour le faire et j'y arrive
encore ne vous inquiétez pas en tout cas
je reviens juste sur cette vision
politique que vous avez parce que vous
avez aussi déclaré nous devons assouplir
le code du travail et ça c'est
d'actualité alléger les charges pour
faciliter la création de véritables
emplois marchands favoriser l'émergence
de nouvelles entreprises
quel regard vous portez sur le toutes
les discussions qui a aujourd'hui sur le
projet de loi qui est porté par la
ministre du travail
meriem elle comme rien que marie ce
qu'il faut voir avant tout c est ce qu
il faut changer les choses en france la
réponse est oui et ce que je dis c'est
une évidence
on l'a pas encore ferons sais pas
pourquoi c'est cet immobilisme que nous
avons en fait en france disons le très
clairement qu est ce qu on entend la
rigidité le note code du travail qu'il
faut apporter de la flexibilité et que
le coût du travail en tant que tel et
trop cher il faut de toute façon qu on
règle ça donc faut-il une réforme oui on
peut s'étonner quand même du timing de
cette réforme qui vient sur la place
publique alors que personne ne s'y
attend il faut se rappeler quand même
que elle est portée par une ministre qui
a trois mois ne savais même pas quelles
étaient les conditions de refus de
renouvellement d'un contrat à durée
déterminée on voit très bien que cette
loi elle ne l'a pas fait que cette loi a
été faite dans l'urgence le gouvernement
est clairement en fait aux abois car il
se rend compte que rien ne fonctionne et
que tout ce qu'il avait dit tombe à
l'eau aujourd'hui françois hollande ne
l'oublions pas quand même il a mis il a
tout misé sur l' inflexion de la courbe
du chômage il se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui un nom de 2017 il n'y
arrive pas il fait une loi très très
vite qui n'a aucune chance de passer
pour vous cette loi n'est pas bonne dans
les propositions qui sont faites
voilà l'accord collectif pour porter
un seuil de 12 heures la journée de
travail par exemple
elle a duré cinq heures moi ce qui me
choque évidemment il faut remettre en
cause les 35 heures mais ce qui me
choque c'est que le même gouvernement
les socialistes depuis 16 ans ont
expliqué qu'il n'y avait rien de mieux
et que c'était sacraliser les 35 heures
12 milliards d'euros par an de coûts
pour la france vous rajoutez la
désorganisation dans les services
publics et aujourd'hui on la foule au
pied en une loi en nous expliquant qu'il
faut remettre de l'ordre et qu'il faut
simplifier le code du travail c'est de
l'amateurisme
on se moque du monde j'en viens à 7k
double carrière que vous menez aussi
bien en politique que dans votre vie
professionnelle lors de votre première
victoire en 2008 vous vous insistiez sur
le rôle de l'équipe municipale
l'importance de des employés municipaux
aussi aujourd'hui comment vous
travaillez avec eux est ce que est ce
que ce sont tous et tous et tous ses
employés des sources des deux
propositions d'idées pour le pot est
alors c'est très très drôle que vous
m'en parliez parce que justement nous
avons initié un processus avec eux
d'amélioration de tout le fonctionnement
au niveau de la ville
ils doivent travailler sur qu'est ce
qu'il est possible d'améliorer déjà pour
l'image dont ils sont carrément partie
prenante avec nous et surtout parce que
sinon je ne serais pas le maire de ville
peut faire moins cher
je dirais que oui on les a mis au coeur
de notre engagement et de notre projet
parce qu'on sait très bien sans eux sans
léser sans les employés communaux
on ne peut pas faire ce dont nous avons
vu ce que nous avons envie de faire
donc il faut travailler en fête avec eux
ça a été long parce qu'il a fallu
également via u11 choc du fonctionnement
on leur a demandé d'oublier ce qu'il
avait fait avant pour adopter un mode de
fonctionnement plus efficace et donc ça
n'a pas été simple mais maintenant
depuis plusieurs années on travaille
d'une manière très intéressante avec eux
et tout se passe bien au niveau de la
ville on arrive quasiment à la fin de
cet entretien je voudrais vous faire
écouter un extrait sain discours de deux
pierre laurent
pas forcément votre bord politique
grands noms mais les mots qu'il va
prononcer vont peut-être vous rappeler
quel qu'il soit par contre moi je vous
souhaite des rêves à n'en plus finir et
longvic furieuse de réaliser quelques
uns
je vous souhaite des mais ce qu'il faut
aimer et d'oublier ce qu'il faut oublier
je vous souhaite des patients je vous
souhaite des silences
je vous souhaite des chants d'oiseaux au
réveil et des rires d'enfants
je vous souhaite de respecter les
différences des autres parce que le
mérite et la valeur de chacun sont
souvent à découvrir
je vous souhaite de résister à
l'enlisement à l'indifférence est
ouverte une négative de notre époque
je vous souhaite enfin de ne jamais
renoncer à la recherche à laventure à la
vie à l'amour car la vie est une
magnifique aventure nuls de raisonnable
ne doit y renoncer
sans livrer une rude bataille je vous
souhaite surtout d'être vous fier de
l'être est heureux car le bonheur et
notre destin véritable bercy hier
laurent déjà c'est vrai là elle est tout
à fait jacques brel vous l'avez citer
aussi je devais m'arrêter au voeu 2015
alors j'avais mieux lui je crois bien la
différence et c'est tombé dessus donc
c'était jacques brel en 68 et c'est vrai
que c'est plutôt drôle qu'on est
dit les mêmes choses s'étaient
finalement quel que soit le bord
politique jacques brel bah c'est
peut-être sa tête c'est finalement parce
que jacques brel plutôt plutôt
sympathisants de gauche aux nécessités
alors ça c'est clair ça m'est
complètement égal c'est peut être une
force pour pour moi je ne me fie pas sur
la couleur pour me dire c'est quelqu'un
de bien ou pas et là la preuve suis
tombé sur ça je me souviens c'était au
niveau des au moment des attentats
j'avais regardé je m'étais dit pas c'est
peut-être par ces mots que j'ai envie de
commencer le discours des voeux et je
pense que c'était en fait des mots très
très beau et avec une fournée les gens
avaient envie d'entendre sa carrière
politique juste pour conclure vous ne
l'avez dit c'est pas forcément votre
finalité ci aux prochaines élections
nous n'étiez pas reconduit vous
continuerez votre vie
professionnellement malgré tout je vais
être conduit j'espère malgré tout vous
étiez candidat sur les régionales aux
côtés de valérie pécresse en 2000 tout à
fait alors c'était parce qu'en fait
quand j'ai commencé en 2008 c'était un
peu la première fois j'ai cheminé d'être
élu et je m'étais dit pourquoi pas aller
plus loin et portait justement la force
que j'avais dans ses premiers mois plus
loin et pour accompagner 20 valérie
pécresse dans ce beau projet qu'est ce
que je le regrette avec le temps
peut-être pas je pense que ça avait été
assez mal perçu par les gens qui
m'avaient fait confiance quelques mois
avant ce dont je m'étais présenté sans
étiquette en 2008 un an après je partais
avec elle on se rebelle arrêtez ça avait
été dur mais je ne le regrette pas aussi
il faut jamais regretter je regrette
simplement ne pas avoir été élu ça c'est
dommage mais je la fais je la félicite
qu'elle ait gardé également la même
force pour être élu dès 2015 donc on
vous retrouvera pas sur une liste à part
aux régionales
je ne crois pas donc jamais dire jamais
mais pour le pour le moment je suis très
heureux en tant que mère je me donne à
fond depuis 2008
encore plus maintenant j'ai un nouveau
de challenges essayer de gérer le budget
correctement au niveau de st de
saint-quentin je vais me consacrer à
cela dans les prochains mois
merci stéphane rambaud merci à vous
merci